à seulement trois ans et demi la vie de
camilla a déjà bien changé en quelques
jours parti de kiev est arrivé le 21
février en france avec sa mère jelena
elle se retrouve aujourd'hui scolarisés
en maternelle dans le village de metz un
nouvel environnement et une nouvelle
culture elle qui vivent aujourd'hui chez
la tante de jelena pour l'instant ça se
passe bien après il faut laisser le
temps de prendre ses repères parce qu'il
ya quand même la barrière de la langue
voilà donc il ya quelques mots
on l'a pris quelques monde ukrainien en
cours pour les choses essentielles à
bonjour je veux faire pipi par exemple
voilà ce qui lui permet de communiquer
un petit peu avec avec les adultes
surtout après une semaine de classe
l'adaptation se fait naturellement même
si la communication reste parfois
difficile
l'apprentissage qui nécessite quelques
ajustements au niveau de l'enseignement
je suis heureuse de voir ma fille comme
ça elle court elle joue elle va à
l'école avec le sourire pour l'instant
ils ne se comprennent pas bien avec les
autres enfants mais elle a le sourire
c'est plus grand bonheur pour moi un
élan de solidarité pour camilla et sa
mère qui n'espère plus qu'une chose
retrouver enfin une vie normale